hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show so
i'm hosting in studio socially distance
because we all must protect
ourselves senator ted cruz and the
excremental michael moles
they are the host of verdict with ted
cruz so before i talk to them here's a
little bit of what the trailer looks
like
we're sitting here right now it is 2 42
in the morning you've come here
straight from the hill senator ted cruz
has a nightly podcast
called verdict
can you just take us through this
process a little bit those rules are
designed so you don't have senators
screaming at each other the house has a
lot of that
i still remember when they pulled up
porn on the screen justice o'connor just
went
oh my you're saying ukraine and not
russia
that logical construct x and not y
they're engaging in lawyerly sleight of
hand
the u.s government was funding
the chinese research at the wuhan
institute of virology
the senate acquitted president trump
about 4
30 in the afternoon that's right they're
not done this has released the hounds
what in the hell are you freaking nuts
you guys are not
friggin overlord get off your power trip
it still doesn't matter if there's a
quid pro quo okay you showed off your
latin in the early episodes
there's been a real cynicism in this
whole issue of the protests just a week
ago we were told
if you go outside to do anything you're
killing grandma you're endangering
people
because of the coronavirus and then this
week we're told
everybody should go out to protest
the world's number one podcast and
number one in news
we passed joe rogan we rose to number
one we are
beating the new york times i'm sorry
could you say that again
[Applause]
the number one podcast in the entire
country what is a podcast
alrighty guys so that's a great trailer
so you have a lot to live up to
particularly you knows i mean
you know i i have to say ben i i
couldn't hear i
i always hear you call me the excellent
michael knowles and i don't know it was
maybe like
my ear pieces off i also hate to have to
compliment you after that
you look great i haven't seen you in
like two months you look fantastic well
i'm a year older
[Laughter]
ray in my hair i've lost some weight
right and and you look
basically the same i mean i i don't have
much to say about that but
so so i'll say two things one
i've done a lot of shows with you in a
lot of podcasts with you now and this is
the first time you've ever been greeted
by your colleague and business partner
as a piece of crap so
so i'm just saying that that's true
you're late to the game senator this has
been
um but but i'll say secondly and and i
don't know if you remember the old
old saturday night lives but i have to
admit when when you when you looked at
that and complimented him and i was
immediately taken back to
rule look marvelous i gotta say for me
is
it's more important to look good in the
field
so senator cruz you've been doing this
show this with this terrible person
how's that been going for you uh we're
having a blast
we've been doing uh doing the verdict
podcast we started
january of this year uh started on the
first day of the impeachment trial and
as you know we've been talking about
doing this for over a year
um you remember last summer i was out
here was talking with you was talking
with mike was talking with
all the team here about we got to do a
better job fighting for the hearts and
minds of the american people
explaining the constitution the bill of
rights explaining free speech explaining
religious liberty explaining the second
amendment explaining free enterprise
versus socialism
connecting and getting around the media
and this has been a burden on my heart a
long long time you guys do a
fabulous job kind of all of the the the
multi-headed hydra that
has now grown out of here all of it is
advancing the cause of liberty
and in fact we were laughing about last
summer when we were out here we went out
to dinner
in l.a we're talking about we should do
a podcast at the table across the
restaurant from us was adam schiff
and this before the whole impeachment
thing and there he was just sort of
sitting there
that is some weird providence but it
does it does feel like there's been a
little bit of providence going on
because you know we were talking about
this
this show with the senator a year ago
impeachment happens we do it we launch
it every single night
and you know i have great admiration for
the senator high expectations for the
man
i did not expect he would hit number one
on the charts i did not expect that the
senator would beat joe rogan but i think
what it what it speaks to is that
there's this idea that the american
people they're idiots they don't want
any information about their government
they don't care they
and i don't think that's the case i
think they just want more than
five-minute dumbed-down sound bites i
mean this is why your show is you know
fastest growing conservative podcast in
america that's why i think verdict
jumped up to number one in the first few
weeks that it launched
people want to see behind the scenes
they want to talk about the issues in
their government
they just want to be respected when when
that's happening well i mean
that's one of the best things about the
show is that you do go behind the scenes
and i remember during the impeachment
your insight as to what was going on
behind the scenes was absolutely vital
to understand what was going on
in reality because the media's narrative
of these events and what's actually
happening
are two completely different stories and
that's that's what i think people really
appreciate about a verdict
well that's really what we're trying to
do is is explain the substance and
and so we started the first night of the
impeachment trial
and during the day i'm obviously in the
trial in the senate and and the trial
would end
midnight one two in the morning and i'd
jump in a truck i'd head over and we'd
record it live at two in the morning and
and it would be
immediate real time here's what just
happened and it would be
let's get into the facts the facts were
complicated ukraine what what's ukraine
what does that have to do with russia
with you with the u.s
barisma what the natural gas who's
hunter bible
and then they're the legal issues
they're the constitutional issues what
what is a high crime or misdemeanor what
does that mean and we tried to get into
all of that
with with real substance it's so hard if
you're an informed consumer if you
care about what's going on in this
country it's really hard because the
media is a train wreck you've got
media on the left media on the right too
many they're almost all propagandists
they're putting out
a a political spin and if you're trying
to understand okay what's really
happening
it's hard and so the the verdict podcast
what we try to do is is
have candid have real discussions these
are the facts that
this is the law this is what's going on
and and what you put it out to give
an inside perspective so it's not just
on paper here the issues but
what are the conversations going on in
the senate cloak room what are
individual senators saying what are the
what senators are on the fence that may
vote yes may vote no
what's the strategy of the trump legal
team and i was talking to the trump
legal team every day and i'd go
you know we had one of the verdict
podcasts where i laid out this should be
their closing argument we did it on the
podcast and
it was driving what was
moving forward and then since
impeachment ended we continue to do the
podcast about one a week
and and and it's the same sort of thing
we try to do a deep dive
into issues so so for example we had
had tim scott my colleague tim scott on
talking about
racism talking about police reform
and it's interesting tim in the middle
of the the podcast he pulls out a cell
phone and he plays
on his cell phone two nasty
racist voicemails he got from leftists
who were furious
with him that as a black man he was
actually standing is a republican was
standing up to
ex-cripple his child's play compared to
the stuff that tim scott
and it was it was vicious and we were
also having fun so one of my favorite
episodes we did
a couple of weeks ago we had bill bar on
now now barr as you know he's a terrific
lawyer he does media interviews and and
they're usually what six seven minutes
hostile lefty reporter pounding him
coming after him just how corrupt are
you sir
and and bar is buttoned up and he's
careful and he gives answers
now bill and i have been friends for 25
years i've known him since i was a
baby lawyer coming out of clerking for
the court and and he's been
been a a friend and a mentor for a long
time
and so we had him on for half hour did
it at doj
and it was and we weren't trying to do
gotcha questions it's not like i'm
trying to it was
let's talk about the big issues let's
talk about uh
social media spying and censorship let's
talk about
violent riots let's talk about people
tearing down monuments how we're going
to stop it
and and we had a conversation and i got
to say ben the most frequent comment we
get whether it's on
on youtube on the podcast or it's on on
the podcast on whatever
platform most frequent comment is you
know i learned something here
and like the bill barr episode a number
of people wrote wow i didn't know barr
was so funny
and he's got this dry sardonic wit
and my favorite exchange in it we're
going back and forth and i think bill
has
been really steadfast in the face of
just getting pounded by a media storm
and he's been willing to take on the
deep state in a way that was desperately
needed
and and so i just were talking i said
you know you know what bill
you're the honey badger and candidly
when i said it i didn't really think
look bill's older than you and i are
i didn't really think he'd know what i
was talking about and what was
fascinating is he knew exactly what i
was talking about he he knew the
meme he knew you know honey badger don't
care and it was
it was hysterical so michael you've been
interacting with a lot of the
folks that you're interviewing and i
think one of the best things about the
show also is that
exactly what you're talking about these
sort of long-form interviews with people
who you only see for five minutes
on tv and i mean it certainly applies to
you senator cruz is
the people's perceptions are shaped in
the first 30 seconds they see you on tv
but being able to do long-form michael
with all these folks has it shifted your
perceptions of any of them
interpersonally
entirely because you know the senator
obviously
gets to be number one podcaster but also
one of his
unsung accomplishments he's a great
booking producer so you get these really
these really great characters on here
and one thing that astounded me and
actually continues to astound me
is the role of personal relationships in
all of this you know politics
is about people that's that's what it
comes from and so i just had this
thought going into impeachment and going
into all the issues we've dealt with
since the pandemic the lockdown china
i thought it's all kind of pre-planned
it's all set
the personal interactions don't matter
and then hearing these stories
what's going on in the cloakroom what
was said by senator so-and-so at the
desk right next
because we heard an argument that was
given that we didn't expect
hearing these things how this can change
in real time i guess the
the silver lining to the storm cloud of
all this craziness that we see in
politics now
is the reminder that it it's not
inevitable
no no end of this is inevitable that
actually the free choices of the people
who are shaping what's going on
really do matter and you really can make
a difference right up until uh the very
last moment
well one of the things that i think
helps on on the podcast is if we
and we'll sit down and talk michael and
i will talk and say okay who do we want
like if we want to guest we don't always
have a guess but who do we want
and it does help that that a lot of the
folks we might want are friends of mine
and i
you know you know we wanted one of tim
scott i sent him a text um
we you know decided all right mark
meadows the the new
chief of staff of the white house mark
is a very close friend
and so i said mark a text said hey would
you do the podcast he texts right i mean
like
30 seconds later sure he's happy to
first sit down
that mark meadows the white house chief
of staff has done since he became chief
of staff we and and he just
talks candidly about what the job is
like
that has been a helpful thing i have to
say i think my favorite interview was
early on
with lindsey graham and and lindsay okay
so this this was during impeachment come
in and number one the
the studio we were using is in dc it was
it was in a basement and it was actually
relatively rough part of town in fact as
a result of the podcast
our truck was broken into my briefcase
was stolen much to my
great annoyance like day three michael
what's your alibi well you know
i didn't notice him like marrying my
briefcase the next day i sort of
wondered about it very similar oh no
it's a
different shade it actually though the
defense we always have is
we're fiscal conservatives on this show
we're not wasting money we're in a bad
part of town we've got the basement
studio so the basement studio we're
going down these like concrete steps in
a basement studio lindsay's going around
going
okay does anyone know where i am if i'm
like disappear in the basement in dc
like like you have a record of me and
then we get down
and and our studio look it's it's uh
not terribly fancy we got a couple of
chairs that we're not super expensive
we've got gigantic
mics that are like this the size of a
football in your face
um we've got a shag carpet from from the
1970s
that i think they like bought at a flea
market somewhere
and and lindsay's first comment he looks
around goes
what in the hell is a podcast
and then he looks at all the team and
goes
you guys are children don't you have any
adults here i'm like lindsay we need to
talk people who aren't just blue haired
like actually
connect with some young people and so
we're sitting there doing the interview
and lindsay looks around at our shag
carpet everything else and he goes
so you guys are the number one podcast
in the world
who in the hell is number two some guy
in a van at a park
like what or what and it was
it was side splitting because it was
genuine it was his real reaction and he
was completely
confused why this wasn't the green room
at fox and
and and what it meant you know i mean he
tossed some things out there he's like
can i say this yeah you can say whatever
you want this is a conversation
you know better than anybody ben i mean
there you know this mainstream media
apparatus that has existed now for a
very long time
acts as a gatekeeper and it it
propagates its own system but it doesn't
like to get views out
that that it doesn't want to get out and
so when you come out there
even when you started your show you were
in a pool house down the street
and somehow getting that message out
even in that way
okay it's the right decision not to do
it in a speedo though even
though that was that was a good call
yeah i don't know how the ratings would
have played out but
but even even that you know i think
there is a hunger for these kinds of
this kind of information and the
audiences are simply not being served
by a desiccated old form so senator
let's talk a little bit about the news
you're now banned in china
until such time as you actually enter
the nba based on your obvious
obvious skill level once you're in the
nba then apparently you can
basically do what you want with china
you've seen your way back in you have
solved look look my dream
politics is fun but if i could be
anything it would be be the start
starting shooting guard on the on the
houston rockets
other than the fact that i can't really
dribble i can't really shoot and i have
about a two inch vertical jump
other than that i am perfectly qualified
for it um
i i like that solution uh look
what a bizarre thing so it was actually
when i was out here we're
filming some podcasts doing different
interviews and and i go to bed a couple
nights ago
wake up in the morning my my cell phone
is my alarm clock so i wake up look at
my cell phone first thing and i've got
like four texts
that says yeah the the government of
china just sanctioned you last night
like what and like the communist
government of china has issued formal
sanctions against me i am
banned from china now i have to admit i
kind of laughed and said well gosh you
know
uh the family and i we were planning
such a wonderful vacation in beijing i
heard they have lovely beaches and you
know we
were playing i mean and i have to say
look
i despise communists
um as you know my family when it comes
to communism and suffering under
communism
my father was was beaten and tortured by
batista's thugs my aunt mighty esonja
was beaten and tortured by castro's
thugs
and and the chinese communists they are
murdering
torturing evil lying bastards
who have a million uyghurs in
concentration camps they have a
one-child policy with force
sterilization
forced abortion they engage in rampant
censorship they engage in
massive theft of intellectual property
their cover-up
on the wuhan coronavirus is directly
responsible for a half million people
who have died
and you know we're at an interesting
moment now where suddenly people in
washington are discovering gosh there's
some problems with the chinese
government
and and all those folks a whole lot of
democrats including joe biden have been
huge apologists and cheerleaders for for
china forever
a whole lot of republicans have been
with them
in the eight years i've been in in the
senate i have been
leading the fight to say china is the
single
greatest geopolitical threat facing the
united states
for the next century and and and we need
to stand up against them and that's
that's why they've sanctioned me because
it's
um you know last october i traveled to
asia and i went to
to pearl harbor to japan to taiwan
to india and hong kong and it was
designed to be a friends and allies
tours all around china
it's major friends and allies to
highlight now the chinese by the way
said
don't you dare go to taiwan don't meet
with president tsai and i said
go jump in a lake i'm going to meet with
whoever the hell i want so i went on
their national day
when they had had parades and stood next
to the president for the parade for
china's national day
in hong kong two million protesters on
the streets of hong kong i met with a
number of the protesters
many of them are kids they're teenagers
they're high school kids or college kids
um who are being brutalized victimized
and they're heroically standing up
against chinese communist depression
i've said a number of times
hong kong is the new berlin and and i
ended up i did a
sunday show dressed in all black
in solidarity with the protesters
because that's what they were wearing
and their chief executive
the the chinese apparatchik who who runs
hong kong
when i got there they ordered her not to
meet with me so i was like great i'll
just beat the crap out of you if
you're afraid to even talk with me all
the better i'll talk with the people
standing up to you
and so i do think what they did in the
pandemic
presented a moment in time where people
are realizing just how dangerous and
malevolent they are
and i also think the most significant
foreign policy
consequence of this pandemic is going to
be a fundamental reassessment of
america's
relationship with china and also the
world's relationship with china and
don't forget you know
we talk about joe biden as though
compared to some of the radicals he's
the more moderate
moderate guy but on this issue of china
joe biden
has cheered on china's rise for decades
including
in recent years he sure there were many
people actually in both parties who did
it but he did it in particular and now i
think we're realizing
very conservative principle which is
that there's no such thing as a free
lunch
and now now we're beginning to bear the
cost and the consequences of that
decision so senator on a broader level
it feels like the country is
under significant strain the likes of
which we haven't seen certainly for
decades between
covet 19 and between the the riots and
the protests and
a generalized perception that seems to
be prevailing in mainstream media that
if you disagree with nicole hannah jones
you must be ousted from your job
it seems as though things are going
exactly the wrong direction
how do you think this turns around
particularly given the fact that you
know the polls are so negative for
republicans right now not just on the
national level but also in so many
states
so in in terms of the election let's
start with that for a second
i i think it is enormously volatile
i think much of it depends on what
happens between now and election day i
think if we
see the covid numbers get
more under control if we see the cases
and the hospitalizations and deaths go
down
i think if we see places opening up
people going back to work people getting
jobs
if we see a renewed sense of optimism
that people feel we don't have to have
all 44 million of the jobs back
immediately that were lost
but we have to be people have to see
this is coming we're coming back
if we have that optimism i think we
could see a terrific election i think we
could see president trump reelected i
think we could see
us grow our majority in the senate i
think we could retake the house
on the other hand though if the covid
numbers go up
if more and more people get affected if
more more people get hospitalized if the
death numbers keep going up
if we see more and more shutdowns if
people are losing their jobs
and if they're dispirited and
demoralized and losing hope
this could be a bloodbath i mean we
could lose the white house
we we could lose the senate we could
lose the house and the
damage that that would do to the country
would be massive and
i don't recall an election with that
that kind of delta that kind of
volatility
and right now the media there are a
couple of things going on the media and
democratic politicians want
scenario b they want the electoral
bloodbath which means
just about every elected democrat is is
vested in
maximizing misery between now and
election day it's why gavin newsom has
shut down california why they don't want
anyone to go to school because they
want an election day everyone at home
everyone broke everyone's savings gone
everyone hopeless their kids screaming
because they can't go to school
and they want a bunch of pissed off
people to vote against trump by the way
if god forbid biden's elected i'm
predicting right here today
the week after the election suddenly
everything will be magically cured
suddenly
you can go back to work avenues and will
say california is open for business go
to jobs the schools will open
there's so much political garbage being
played
but part of what the media is also
trying to do is get conservatives to
give up hope
listen the poll number's a little rocky
now there's no doubt about that
but they're repeating i i i mean it
it is abandoned hope all ye who enter
they they want you just to stay home and
give up
and and we can't do that you ask how do
we
turn it around part of it is the media
is so
they don't pretend they're unbiased they
are propagandists
they are consumed by loathing for trump
which means what you're doing every day
what we're doing
with the podcast with the show getting
around the mainstream
media i think is the path to saving this
country because the media won't let the
truth through that they're not
willing to discuss it to consider it
and and and so we've got to have
real discussions with real people
on facts and substance here's how
republicans win the election in november
if the election is a substantive policy
choice between two visions
between free enterprise and socialism
between america as a land of hope and
opportunity
or america is an evil oppressive
wasteland that must be destroyed
if that's the choice if it's a choice
between the constitution and bill and
rights and your fundamental liberties
versus the mob and violence and terror
and oppression
and conformity and mccarthyist
censorship which is where the angry left
is
that's an easy choice we don't just win
that election we win that election
big what the left wants is they don't
want any of those issues discussed they
want it to be a pure personality choice
they want joe biden to stay hidden in
his basement
say nothing do nothing he's like the the
the monkeys see no evil do no evil speak
no evil he ain't gonna see speaker do
because they want it just to be a you
know frankly like a
a kardashian referendum on personality
and listen they're a bunch of people who
love trump bunch of people who hate
trump and if the only election is all
right which side of the like tribal war
are you on
right now the democrats think they win
that battle we need to make it about
issues and substance we need to make it
about america
so what do you think the likelihood is
of that happening i mean given that the
media coverage is so overwhelming and
yeah we're all sort of resisting that
but but it is you know a tsunami of
media coverage
and as you say if the news continues to
be bad it makes it very difficult which
really suggests that the president
doesn't have tons of agency in this
particular scenario that
that everybody is sort of a victim of
circumstance from now until election day
is there anything that you think that
the president can do that would that
would
affect where we are right now sure there
are lots of things he could do
um message discipline has never been a
strength of this white house
part of the problem is when things are
going well
the president shoots himself in the foot
with with some
tweet sent at two in the morning through
through
passion look the stakes are really high
like stop
screwing around like drive a concerted
real message um
all right let's take today today the
president was asked
do black lives matter and he gets angry
and saying well white lives matter what
with all due respect mr president that's
not the answer to give
if the media is trying to paint anyone
who disagrees with
with their
angry violent mobs as a racist
giving an answer that is focused on
white people is is
about like
how about the following answer
mr president do black lives matter
absolutely
black lives are precious
african-american lives are precious and
i'm going to say it's really sad
when you see the violent angry left
calling for abolishing the police
that has already resulted in crime
skyrocketing we're going to see more
murders we're going to see more rapes
we're going to see more people assaulted
and tragically a great many of those
people are african-americans
great many of them are hispanics great
many of them are low-income they're
living in the inner cities
and as a result of the angry left that's
attacking police officers that's
vilifying police officers by the way
many of whom are themselves
black or hispanic we're seeing more
black lives lost
and more hispanic lives lost and more
white lives lost and
every life is a precious gift from god
and and right now joe biden
if he wants to be president needs to
stand up
and defend the police he needs to make
clear that the
angry marauding mobs he doesn't stand
with he needs to make clear
that keith ellison the democratic
attorney general of minnesota
who says he stands with antifa the
violent terrorists
who are murdering police officers joe
biden needs to make clear
that keith ellison has no place in his
party because if you stand with violent
murdering terrorists
you don't belong in the political
process we need to be on the affirmative
and we need to be also you know when you
talk about
black lives matter
the mobs initially started
talking about confederate statues but
then they moved to george washington
and thomas jefferson and james madison
then they began attacking and defacing
abraham lincoln and ulysses s
grant abraham lincoln signed the
emancipation
proclamation led the fight to end
slavery
ulysses grant moved defeated the
confederacy in the civil war and moved
to crush the kkk which by the way was
founded
by democratic politicians
and it reached really the point of
absurdity
when the leftist mobs defaced a statue
of frederick douglass the great
abolitionist african-americans spoke
against the horror of slavery and and
and the angry mobs that are doing this
they hate america when you're defacing
frederick douglass
we're going to defend frederick douglass
we're going to defend the principles of
this country
and we're going to defend every black
life in america we're going to defend
every hispanic life in america we're
going to defend every life in america
because
that's what this country is about that
actually
so let me say something in defense and
then in criticism in defense
some of that messaging was actually what
the president said at mount rushmore
right
and and that was an excellent speech it
was well written
of course the media engaged rabid
revisionism and called it dark and
divisive
and they said it was racist they just
totally lied
and you had by the way uh one of my
colleagues democratic senator
tammy duckworth said the president gave
a speech at mount rushmore defending
confederates
he literally didn't mention a single
confederate he mentioned
george washington thomas jefferson teddy
roosevelt and abraham lincoln
and apparently that's who she thinks are
confederates among others
martin luther king jr he mentioned i
think three times he did he talked about
uh dr king but the problem is we need to
have
if we know the media are rabidly biased
partisan
liars which is what they are right now
we need to have the message disciplined
to drive a consistent message not to
give them the fodder
and right now the
the president's campaign is not
providing that it's just sort of
reacting to whatever
happens that day
if what i said is right that we win if
this election is a fundamental choice
between two visions for america
we got to explain the fundamental choice
we've got to explain
what's going on because the media won't
do it for us and and so i hope that we
see from the president his campaign team
a lot more
systematic effort to do that well
senator cruz the expert will michael
knowles thanks so much for stopping by
everybody should give a listen to the
verdict with ted cruz
and also by the way with michael go
check that out right now thanks guys for
stopping by i really appreciate it thank
you man
this video is sponsored by blink sale it
is the revolutionary invoicing software
for small businesses spend less time
building more time
making the money with blingsale go down
to the link in our description and give
it a click